what's up little otter what's up little
otter little otter
uh wants to get back up here
otters so soft cuddly
adorable but underneath all that
cuteness
there's a dark side this is the dark
side of otters
in six minutes
[Music]
ready go my business sometimes the cuter
the animal
is the more dangerous it is and that
seems to be the case for otters
take it from dave lueck who runs a
humane nuisance wildlife trapping
business in florida
as cute as they are there can be like
three foot of muscle
all they do is swim all day long for the
most part they have
razor sharp claws teeth you do see those
things in the wild you want to keep it
at a distance so i always cringe when i
see people trying to get really close to
an otter that's in the water to get
pictures
it's like yeah you kind of want to stay
your distance people they just they look
at them just because they're just so
cute on those videos and they really are
cute especially baby ones if you get
them they have this really high-pitched
squeal
you know i love otters well you can't be
like oh i love him i'm not gonna hurt
him
it's a wild animal it's nature can be
brutal sometimes
it might just be playing and it can take
your finger off otters may be
much stronger and faster than they look
i often tell people the animal i'm most
scared of that i deal with
is an otter you'd be surprised how
strong they are for the size
those things are just swimming and
eating and chasing fish
they're long and slender very muscular
otters i mean they can get up
almost three foot long here in florida
20 pounds although i've had one that was
25
pounds in other parts of the world
otters can grow
up to 99 pounds otters are also
extremely intelligent they tend to
forge together cooperatively they will
actually swim down rivers in these
v-shapes
and round up fish together otters can do
sustained attacks
like i said they are smart they can keep
coming back and come back
they can kind of you know think out the
situation and what's the best way to go
at you
otters whether territorial or rabid may
also attack family pets
otter probably had just moved into that
area so
he probably sees that dog as a threat
smaller dogs are the ones are going to
get killed
they possibly could be seen as prey they
would go after ducks and things like
that
bigger dogs can have a better chance
against an otter
especially if it's on land but it's
usually right on the edge of the water
most things aren't going to have a
chance against an otter in the water
including a person
in states like florida humans have
pushed deeper into the otter's natural
habitat
and otters have pushed back past year
locally a lady in a kayak um got
attacked but
why they did it maybe she was kayaking
right by that den
and the mom was just protecting her
babies there there have been
you know reports of rabid otters
attacking people
in sarasota there was an elderly
gentleman walking down the road
and a rabid otter knocked him to the
ground and was just going at him and uh
there was a 9-1-1 call of it i remember
they played it on the news
please that's an honor who's got him
an honor it's horrific finally they did
get it off from even hitting
the shovels and stuff like that and i
think he ended up in the emergency room
those aren't even the most disturbing
stories about these adorably dangerous
creatures
otters sometimes engage in such
astonishingly perverse
acts it almost sounds like it must be a
joke
my husband told me that otters rape
baby seals he wanted to ruin otters for
you he had to look up that fact
it's true by the way comedian michelle
wolf
is right it's true we're ruining otters
for you and sadly
it's based on actual research according
to a study published in the scientific
journal
aquatic mammals instances of male otters
engaged in
forced copulation with juvenile pacific
harbor seals were reported at least 19
times in monterey bay california
between 2000 and 2002. the accounts are
graphic
and unfortunately not an uncommon
occurrence
before intercourse in one case the otter
gripped the seal's head with its four
paws
and bit it on the nose the otter held
the seal pup's head
underwater the seal pup did not survive
the encounter
nature's very brutal raping of the other
species and otter
there's probably a reason why they're
doing that
the study's authors theorize that this
behavior was a result of the dominance
hierarchy of otters
and an increase in the number of males
relative to females which can lead to
scarcity for mating everything in
wildlife
is just eat or be eaten you know every
second of the day
is what can i do to survive or not get
eaten
so otter's just doing what otter does
they don't you know have to go to
you know otter court or anything like
that and explain their actions
anything goes on wildlife and there's
usually a reason
behind everything they're doing how can
otters be so cute and so dangerous at
the same time
well the real answer is that's just
nature if we're shocked to learn about
the dark side of otters or
other wild animals it's likely because
we were imposing our own
human morality onto nature a lot of
people with otters they try to
anthropomorphize them
it's just projecting human traits on
them but people just
you know don't realize they are wild
animals it's not that it's just some
evil otter that's going out
and that includes projecting how
adorable they are but
don't worry you can still love otters
but
if you see an otter and want to share a
video of its cute little face
remember you might not want to get too
[Music]
[Applause]
close
you